Tenemos la siguiente ecuación con valor absoluto, 5 que multiplica al valor absoluto de "x" más 3,
hasta aquí acaba el valor absoluto,
menos 3 igual a 7.
Y bueno, seguramente cuando tienes una ecuación con valor absoluto, tú te sientes un poco intimidado
o tal vez algo desalentado porque tienes valor absoluto, sin embargo no hay que preocuparnos tanto.
¿Qué te parece si lo primero que hacemos es aislar la parte que tiene que ver con valor absoluto?
Vamos a dejar de un lado de la ecuación esta
parte que tiene que ver con el valor absoluto,
vamos a aislarlo, mientras que todo lo que no tenga que ver con el valor absoluto, vamos a pasarlo del otro lado.
Y para aislar esto, pues lo primero que hay
que hacer es quitar este -3 y ¿cómo?
voy a sumar 3 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
más 3 más 3, ¿y entonces qué me va a quedar?
Bueno, aquí tengo 5 veces el
valor absoluto de "x" más 3...
5 veces el valor absoluto de "x" más 3, -3
más 3, pero -3 más 3 se cancelan,
esto se puede ir, entonces vámonos, esto es igual
a 7 más 3, lo cual es 10.
Y ya empezamos poco a poco a aislar todo lo
que tiene que ver con el valor absoluto,
ya paso a paso, lo estamos dejando cada vez más solo.
Y de hecho si te das cuenta, lo único que
me falta es quitar este 5 que tengo aquí
a la izquierda y para quitarlo, lo que voy
a hacer es dividir ambos lados de la ecuación
entre 5, este lado de la ecuación entre 5,
este lado de la ecuación entre 5.
¿Y qué me queda?
5 veces algo entre 5, pues esto se cancela,
5 por algo y después lo divido entre 5,
pues 5 y 5 se van y entonces solamente me quedaría el algo, que en este caso es el valor absoluto de "x" más 3.
El valor absoluto de "x" más 3 es igual a
10 entre 5, 10 entre 5 es 2 y ¡perfecto!
date cuenta que ya dejamos solo lo que tiene que ver con el valor absoluto de un lado de la ecuación,
ya lo aislamos, mientras que del otro lado de la ecuación, ya no tenemos
nada que tenga que ver con valor absoluto,
solamente tenemos un 2 y por lo tanto,
bueno pues ahora vamos a resolver esta
ecuación como valor absoluto,
que es muy parecida a la que ya habíamos visto.
Fíjate bien, si yo tengo que el valor absoluto
de algo es igual a 2, pues este algo podría
ser 2, el valor absoluto de 2 es 2, es decir
que "x" más 3 podría ser igual a 2,
porque si "x" más 3 fuera 2 cuando le tomo el valor
absoluto pues esto me da 2.
Esta es una posibilidad, porque también fíjate
que el valor absoluto de -2 también es 2,
recuerda que la función valor absoluto lo que hace es mandarte los números negativos
a positivos, multiplicándolos por un menos,
entonces menos por -2 me da 2 positivo
y si el valor absoluto de -2 también es 2, también
podría ser entonces que "x" más 3
fuera igual a -2, porque si "x" más 3 fuera igual
a -2, me quedaría el valor absoluto de -2
y el valor absoluto de -2 pues es 2.
Es decir, que si nosotros tenemos una ecuación
con valor absoluto, tenemos dos posibles resultados,
esto ya lo habíamos visto, o "x" más 3 es
igual a 2 o "x" más 3 es igual a -2
y de hecho, también lo habíamos visto como la distancia, ¿recuerdas?
El valor absoluto es pensar en la distancia
que tenemos al 0, lo que estamos diciendo
aquí es, ¿qué números tienen una distancia de dos unidades para llegar al 0?
y bueno, pues hay dos valores, tener 2, 2 está a dos
unidades del 0 ó -2,
-2 también está a dos unidades del 0, por lo tanto, si lo vemos como distancia
estamos diciendo que "x" más 3 o puede ser 2 ó en su dado caso también puede ser -2.
Y bueno, pues ahora vamos a resolver estas
ecuaciones, está muy sencillo.
Si yo resto 3 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
me queda que ¿"x" es igual a cuánto?
"x" más 3 menos 3, estos dos se cancelan
y 2 menos 3 esto igual a -1,
entonces me quedaría que "x" es igual
a 2 menos 3, lo cual es -1.
Esto en la primera posibilidad que tenemos
y por lo tanto, ésta es nuestra primera solución.
Ahora bien, también tenemos que "x" más
3 es igual a -2, este es nuestro segundo caso,
así que de igual manera voy a restar 3 de
ambos lados de la ecuación
y me queda "x" más 3 menos 3, pues esto solamente "x" y -2 menos 3, lo cual es -5.
Ya tenemos nuestra segunda solución, nuestra segunda respuesta a esta ecuación y por lo tanto,
tanto "x" igual a -1 como "x" igual a -5, ambas son soluciones de esta ecuación
con valor absoluto, que de hecho sería bastante
bueno que lo corroboráramos.
Voy a sustituir primero el valor de "x" igual
a -1, ¿y qué me va a quedar?
5 veces el valor de "x" más 3, pero "x" vale
-1, es decir, 5 veces el valor absoluto de -1 mas 3
y después menos 3,
¿y cuánto es esto?
Vamos a ver si en efecto nos da 7.
-1 más 3, esto es 2, entonces me quedaría
5 veces que multiplica valor absoluto de 2
menos 3, ¿esto a cuánto es igual?
Y bueno, pues ahora voy a aplicar el valor absoluto.
El valor absoluto de 2 es 2 entonces me quedaría 5 por 2 menos 3, pero 5 por 2 es 10 menos 3 esto es 7.
¡Perfecto!
10 menos 3 es 7 y por lo tanto el valor de
"x" igual a -1 cumple esta ecuación.
Ahora, vamos a hacer la prueba o vamos a ver, si realmente funciona también para la otra solución,
"x" igual a -5.
Y me quedaría, si sustituyo el valor de "x",
5 veces que multiplica al valor absoluto de "x" más 3,
pero "x" vale -5, entonces me quedaría, 5 que multiplica al valor absoluto de -5 más 3 menos 3,
¿y cuánto es esto?
5 por el valor absoluto de -2 menos 3.
Y ahora vamos a hacer el valor absoluto, el
valor absoluto de -2 es 2 también,
entonces me quedaría 5 por 2 menos 3, lo cual es 10
menos 3, lo cual también es 7,
entonces también se cumple que la solución "x" igual a 5 al sustituirla en nuestra ecuación original
nos da el valor de 7, por lo tanto, "x" igual
a 1 y "x" igual a -5,
ambas son soluciones de esta ecuación.
Y fíjate que todo es bastante congruente,
cuando yo metí la solución de morado,
obtuve el valor absoluto de 2, porque había supuesto
a "x" más 3 igual a 2
y cuando yo metí la solución de verde, en la parte de amarillo, llegué al valor absoluto de -2
y esto fue porque había supuesto que "x" más 3 sería
igual a -2 y si yo quisiera graficar estas
dos soluciones, déjame hacer de nuevo una
recta numérica,
voy a poner aquí los dos valores de "x".
Así que voy a suponer que éste es el 0,
aquí está el 1,
aquí está el 2 y para atrás el -1, el -2, el -3, el -4, el -5 todavía lo necesito y el -6.
Y bueno, "x" igual a -1, estaría por aquí,
si te das cuenta, éste es el valor cuando
"x" vale -1 y "x" igual a -5, estaría por
acá, déjame cambiar de color,
"x" igual a -5, está justo aquí.
Así que espero que hayas encontrado esto
bastante útil.